Alright, so, remember, Charles, we were talking about
three different kinds of ways of choosing the
inputs to the learner. Okay? So what were
they again? We just looked at two of them.
>> So the learner chooses examples. The teacher, hopefully a nice
one, chooses examples, and then there was the case with the
examples are given to us by nature. And I guess there
was a fourth one, which is. That a mean teacher gives
it to us but I, you know I don't think that's all
that interesting. I tend to think of nature as a mean teacher.
>> Well not only that but in the, at least in
the mistake bound setting that we just looked at again the, the
learner was robust against any choice of where the inputs were coming
from. So mean teacher it would've it would've done just as well.
>> That's a fine point.
>> It doesn't matter when it makes its mistakes, it's only
going to make a fixed number of them no matter what.
>> Okay.
>> So, we've kind of dealt with three
of these but we haven't really talked about the, the
nature chooses case yet. And that's in some ways the most
interesting and relevant and in other ways the most complicated
because you have to really take into consideration this space of
possible distributions. I think now though we're in a pretty
good situation in terms of being able to define some important
terms and we're going to use those terms to get
a handle on this question of what happens when nature chooses.
>> Okay, that sounds reasonable.
>> So computational complexity, we talked about. The, the, how much
computational effort is going to be needed for a learner to convert
to the answer. Sample complexity in the case of a batch,
that is to say, we have a training set. Is how large
is that training set need to be for the learner to
be able to create successful hypothesis. And that's in the batch setting.
In the online setting, we have this notion of a mistake
bound. How many misclassifications can the learner make over an infinite run?
>> Mind
if I ask you a question? You said
something I thought pretty interesting. How, for computational complexity,
you said how much computational effort is needed
for a learner to converge To the right answer.
Is that the, is that a requirement when
you talk about computational complexity? Or is just that
you need to know how much computational effort
is needed for a learner to converge to something?
>> Well, so if it's converging to something and we don't care what
it's converging to, then it's really easy to have an algorithm with low
computational complexity, right? It's just like
return garbage. It runs in constant time.
>> Mm hm.
>> So, yeah, it's in the context of actually
solving the problem, that computational complexity is most interesting.
>> Well, I was going to say, what if a set
of hypothesis that I'm willing to entertain, doesn't include the true concept.
>> good. Right. So in some sense maybe
in that case what we're trying to find is
the best hypothesis in the hypothesis class. But we
can still ask about computational complexity in that case.
So, I was saying successful hypothesis here. By that I
meant, you know, whatever it is that the problem demands that
we return and if it's a hypothesis class that's very
limited we might just return the best thing in that class.
>> Okay.
>> But the important thing here is that we're not going
to talk about computational [LAUGH] complexity,
for the most part. We're going to
focus on sample complexity for the time being. And that's really
the relevant concept when we're talking about the idea of nature choosing.
>> I believe you